The Establishment media Outlets are
collapsing today the Los Angeles Times
laid off 115 employees they wiped out
their entire DC Bureau in an election
year they laid off pretty much all their
sports teams they killed their entire
Tech and business section they laid off
breaking news writers social media
editors the list goes on but what's
really dark is this is just the latest
in months and months and months of
layoffs in the media industry in fact
tens of thousands of journalists have
been laid off in the past year for
reaction we turn now to me when I first
heard this
[Music]
news my oh my what a wonderful day
plenty of
[Music]
sunshine that was me it's the truth it's
actual everything is satisfactual